well first of all i'd say i actually  think i i think i feel feel fear quite  strongly  um so it's not as though  i just have the absence of fear i've i  feel it quite strongly um  but  there are just times when  something is important enough you  believe in it enough that  you you do it in spite of fear  so speaking of important things like  people shouldn't think i i i  i should people should think well i feel  fear about this and therefore i  shouldn't do it um it's normal to be to  feel fear like you'd have to definitely  something mentally wrong if you didn't  feel fear  um  so you just feel it and let the  importance of it drive you to do it  anyway  yeah you know actually something that  can be helpful is fatalism at some  degree  if you just if you just accept the  probabilities  then  that diminishes fear